a vigil was held earlier tonight for
sixteen-year-old ashari Hughes now
Hughes died this past Thursday while she
was playing flag football from a very
rare congenital abnormality but doctors
say that abnormality can cause
arrhythmias or even sudden cardiac death
and tonight we hear from those closest
to her as the vigil was held at
Centennial High School where Shari
previously attended Madison Kimbrough
was there and joins us now live in our
Newsroom with more
it was a packed house
Neil High School's Auditorium with
fellow classmates teachers and teammates
her family and friends sharing how
ashari uplifted so many on and off the
field
she was Delight to all of us
um you could never see ashari without a
smile on her face and if you didn't have
one she'd give you hers shout out to
number seven that was a Shari Hughes
number while playing flag football known
by many in the sports Community her
former coach at Centennial High School
sharing some words about the type of
person and teammate she was well she
came out on the field it's like whenever
she put the ball in her hands or she was
playing defense it was just wow ashari
recently switched high schools and was
playing flag football at Desert Oasis
when she collapsed on the field Thursday
staff immediately began providing
Medical Aid and continued until
paramedics arrived she was rushed to
Saint Rose Dominican Hospital in
Henderson where she later died her
family and friends coming together
Monday evening for the balloon release
and Candlelight vigil sharing memories
about what type of girl ashorei was off
the field she was a straight A student
she played football she never did
nothing I mean this was a a perfect
child I want to say but at the end of
the day when I got the call that I had
lost my grandbaby something went out of
me her smile every no matter what if
even if I was down she was there for me
me and ashari we were very close back in
summer when we were doing football
tryouts and football practices she's
always given me the motivation that I
really needed especially at my lowest
and her grandfather shared with us that
the family was aware that ashari was
having some health issues they went to
get her checked out the week before not
knowing the severity of her condition
but the doctors cleared her to play in
Thursday night's game in The Newsroom
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now